we're living on borrowed time we're just
wallowing in our in our greed in
spiritual fulfill and now it's time to
pay worry we're gonna pay the price
okay somewhat I mean to change the
subject all that your life your coffee
buddy have you had time to look at the
menu I'm gonna prevent the variance of
God if we have no respect for human life
[Music]
she would have just let me race it the
way should have been raised maybe it
would've ended up on the bottom the way
he did praise a paranoid schizophrenic
it's not mom's fault is that anybody's
fault
[Music]
there was an incident
[Music]
what you do if I had kids I would not
let this man near my children I'm
probably more dangerous than he is this
guy is harmless
your brother was placed in a forensic
Hospital because he's seriously mentally
ill
[Music]
I have to take care of my brother that's
just something that I have to do I have
to do it
don't you get it your mom is dying
think you need to let go a little you
don't just give up on the people you
love
for unless beta Omega 2 Ari
[Music]
you
you